welcome to exploring computing
today's video is introduction to python
our first python program so in the last
video we saw how
we could use the python shell as
basically a super calculator
and we played around with a bunch of
different formulas like celsius times 9
divided by 5 plus 32
are kilometers times 0.621
but the way we were doing it last time
we had a bit of a problem because
we need to re-type these formulas every
time we want to use them
and so you know as i suggest the last
time
you can use the python shell as as
basically super calculator but
that's not really creating a program in
order to turn these into programs
we need to store them into a file and be
able to reuse them whenever we want
so it turns out that idle has a built-in
file editor as i suggested last
last video and so if you if you're
running idle
um see last video for how instructions
for how to run idle
um so if you go to the file menu there's
an option there to create a new file so
if you go ahead and do that
the editor will start up and you will
see what's being shown on the bottom
right
now our first attempt here could be just
um to retype what we were previously
typing
into the python shell so remember last
time we started out with just
basically adding a bunch of numbers
together so say i say
3 plus two and go ahead and put that
into our editor here
and when we try and run it by going to
the run menu
in the editor and saying run module it
it's gonna ask us if we wanna save the
file i'm gonna go ahead and save the
file as
example.py python
files are stored with the extension py
and then if i go ahead and run it by
again choosing run
run module it does not do what i expect
here's what's actually going to show up
so if you look at that line with a
restart on there
you kind of see it is attempting to run
my example.py
file but there's no output what's going
on here
well in our python programs we need to
explicitly tell
python that we want to output to our
shell interpreter so
i can do that with what's called a print
function and so
here here it is right here i'm going to
say print and then i have a pair of
parentheses and between the parentheses
i say what i want it to print in this
case i want it to print three plus two
so i say print parentheses three plus
two
and now if i run it sure enough if you
look down there at the second time i've
run it
you can see that it is printing a five
so this is doing what we want
now here i'm i'm printing the results of
carrying on a mathematical equation
i can output other things remember last
lecture we talked about
the fact that python works with integers
it works with floating point numbers it
also works with strings
which allows to manipulate text and so
what i've got down here at the bottom
print quote go stanford quote remember
those quotes indicate that
i have a string of characters g o space
s
t a and f o r and d rather than
i've got some variable named go and a
variable name stanford
and so if i go ahead and say print and i
tell it to print the
string go stanford in fact that's
exactly what it'll do so i had
print three plus two and i had print go
stanford and if we look down here at the
bottom you can see it printed both of
those
okay so last lecture we
converted celsius to fahrenheit so let's
create a little program that
does this conversion for us here's my
first attempt at doing this
okay i go ahead and create a variable
called celsius i store 30 in it
um i carry out my little calculation
there
and store the result in the variable
fahrenheit and then
i've got a fancier slightly fancier
version of the
print statement here quote temperature
and fahrenheit is
end quote comma and then the name of the
variable fahrenheit and that's actually
going to print both of these items out
it's going to print the string
temperature and fahrenheit is and then
it's going to go ahead and print
fahrenheit
and if we go ahead and go to the run
menu
in the editor and we choose run module
sure enough this works it says
temperature it's in fahrenheit is 86
degrees so
that works but there's a bit of a
problem here
and that is my program here includes
setting the celsius variable to 30.
so if it's always 30 degrees out this
program works
but you know if it is always 30 degrees
out
that's not super useful anyway because
i'll probably figure out that's 86
degrees fahrenheit soon enough if it's
30 degrees every day
so um
i want this to change so that instead of
always running with celsius equals 30 i
run with different
temperatures in celsius and in order to
do that i need to
get input from the user and so that's
our next step
to get input from the user i'm going to
use this new input function here i'm
going to say input
i've got a pair of parentheses and
inside that pair of parentheses i'm
going to put a string there that is
going to prompt the user
for the information we want so in our
little example here i'm telling the user
that i want information from them but i
want them to know that the information i
want from them is their name
and when i go ahead and and execute this
input function it's going to return a
value to me that i can store into a
variable so
you know i generally want to say input
enter your name i would actually do what
i've got down here
in the bottom here i would say user
underscore name remember you can use the
underscore in variables
uh user underscore name equals input
enter your name and so
what this code here would do is it would
prompt the user
it would tell the user that we want
their name they would enter their name
and the results of whatever they entered
would be stored in the variable username
where i could use it for other purposes
okay so let's go ahead and take this new
input function and use it in our cell
system fahrenheit program
so i'm going to go ahead and ask the
user to input the
temperature in celsius um and so
you'll notice i've got two lines here uh
why do i have two lines well
the thing is that that input function is
is designed to return
string data types so if the user enters
in
30 i'm not going to get the number 30
i'm actually going to get the string
consisting of a 3 followed by a 0
and i can't use strings directly to
enter into mathematical formulas so i
need to convert the string
three zero into the number three zero
and so
that's what the second line here does
float
is going to take uh something inside the
parentheses there it's what we refer to
as a parameter
it's going to take its parameter and
convert it to a floating point number so
in this case
it will take whatever the user entered
whatever string the user entered
in as the input and it will convert it
to an actual number and it will store
that value into the celsius variable
and if we want we can actually get rid
of the
the intermediate variable here temp i
can put this all in one line i can say
celsius equals request the user enter
the temperature in celsius so the user
will enter the temperature in celsius
and that will be returned that result
that the user has
returned for example the string 3 0 will
immediately be passed
into float and float will
convert it to from the string quote
3 0 to the number 3 0 where we can use
in our mathematical formula and so
here's our program
so i'm going to go ahead and ask the
user to enter the temperature in celsius
i'm going to convert to floating point
number i'm going to store that in the
variable or storage location called
celsius
and i'm going to retrieve the storage
location celsius i'm going to multiply
it by 9 divided by 5 and add 32 to it
i'm going to store that result in
fahrenheit and i'm going to go ahead and
print
temperature in fahrenheit is and then
uh whatever the results in the variable
fahrenheit is
now if you look at the handout i've
actually taken a further step
out of this um and so you could get rid
of the variable here fahrenheit
and just put the celsius times 9 divided
by 5 plus 32 right there into the print
statement
and we could even take it a step further
and we could put this all in one line i
could say
print temperature and fahrenheit is
and then float input enter temperature
in celsius
times 9 divided by 5 plus 32
i haven't done that and actually one of
the reasons why this version is slightly
longer than the version in the handout
is because
the font used for these videos is much
larger and it didn't really fit very
nicely in one line
in the video so you know in general i do
recommend that you break it down into
smaller size steps it's easier to read
and it's harder to make mistakes if you
cram this all into one line it is
technically possible to write this
entire program in a single line of code
but it's going to be hard for people to
figure out what you're doing and it's
going to be super easy for you to
accidentally make a mistake and
it's going to be a little bit hard for
you to track down your error so i don't
really recommend that
okay so uh let's go ahead and run this
program a bunch of times and you can see
uh each of the times it's asking us
please enter the temperature in celsius
so up at the top i said it was 30
degrees and it said oh great
that means the temperature in fahrenheit
is 86. and i re-ran it and said enter
the temperature celsius i set it to 20
degrees
said okay great that temperature is 68
in fahrenheit you know
if the temp heaven forbid the
temperature at celsius is zero
that means the temperature in fahrenheit
is 32 and so on so
um we've created our first program and
you can see that
it's once we've written it it's super
easy to use and it's much easier than
retyping that formula over and over and
over again
and of course if the formula were much
more extensive
it would save us even more time so this
is something that computers are really
great at
and it actually turns out python is
pretty extensively used
across campus in scientific labs and in
fact
different departments like for example
the chemistry department the biology
department have
have sort of emphasized to the computer
science department that they would
really like us to teach python and
that's one of the reasons why we switch
cs106a over to python
all right so that is our first python
program
um next lecture we'll be extending our
programming capabilities to do
more interesting things but i think
that's enough for today and this gives
you an idea of
what programming looks like and how
programming languages work
i'll talk to you soon